pra mim vou botar todos prometem
prolongar uma palavra de agradecimento à
organização pelo convite é uma pessoa
especial é especial pra mim esse tipo de
aposta é que rafael lloreda autos um
banheiro pra ela que não pôde estar aqui
hoje connosco mas quem estava a
acompanhar estas plataformas todas elas
fantásticas e eu fui pro forma também
supera empreendedores já está a avançar
como o brasil todo esse projeto
neste âmbito o link atos que o painel
que estamos aqui
é isso o mote deste deste evento
interessava o que precisa a origem da
pergunta que faço é qual é a origem
deste estava em que nós vivemos hoje em
dia
a moody's elimina tudo isto em resposta
direta é um medo nós e estou a falar em
título individual por cada um de nós
todos vivemos em mesmo hoje em dia e
temos um medo p sul
é o mesmo resulta não só do efetivo
comboio problemas que existem hoje em
dia e que foram furtados vários exemplos
como foi possível superar esses
problemas políticos pela guerra
problemas sociais turnês de
financiamento
somos mulheres com véus todos os dias e
prometeu se como existe objectivamente
os dez provas que é possível superá los
mas principalmente eu também do turno do
que o contratei porque quis porque a
informação que nos chega ea maneira como
ela é transmitida arrasadora obrigatório
o uso do cantor português que gosto
muito tem um dos versos dos seus músicos
numa frase mutável
esse é um homem estava farto de inflação
e meio com o ataque de informação é pai
hoje imagine recontar como foi mas a
casa já não há pachorra para ver como
isto é posto em resolver para todos nós
agora começou a transmitir e portanto
nós passamos a ver o mundo como de
certeza que vai correr mal e portanto
dois amigos que falavam e um de outro
fato já era praticada vez com catarro é
um sintoma de que a barragem sim
eles vão ter button ela disse sempre não
é todo dia que deverão ir até a loja
traz uma pega pra cima e outra vez
moncho ser limpos não tem lá pois o
conceito é o único animal que se não
provar no ensino é também membro ninguém
não salvaram porque isso não pode ser
mãe
e este está paula leva nos a ter mesmo
como ele está mesmo levando a defender é
composto de seis anos caso estivesse a
chover granizo vai confirmar tudo é só
povo
então nós estamos em posição de defesa o
problema é mais agravante é que este
mesmo faz com que a nossa defesa de josé
um provérbio cristiane eu fiz é o ataque
são espécies do mesmo que nós temos
todos a viver hoje em dia experiência
a primeira delas é precisamente a culpa
é sempre do outro
depois quando escutamos nós é para
investigar no completamento né
mas a culpa é do outro nós não assumimos
as responsabilidades terminar fechadas
contra minc sobre a sua vida concluiu
ele não aceita não não chova como é que
é possível então tentou sair para provar
a mulher o a situação é que ela estava
foi chamado por ela e várias jóias da
casa e começou passava por e mail que o
jantar e chega só quando maria ou
jantarem já na cozinha velha senhora
junto ao órgão de trânsito que ajudarem
mesmo em cima da linha já tem gente que
é frango à mãe
mas porque quer dizer é a senhora que
absurdo né
esse é o outro nome que interessa mesmo
é mais fácil ocupa que o casal e um
homem muito concentrado numa acção de
janeiro
tu tens a mania que eu acho tem sempre
razão está muito enganado
não tava eu tenho a minha mãe jane que
acha que eu tenho cinco a vantagem de
ganhar vai facilitar para esta realidade
da culpa que agora nós projetamos as
coisas para viver isso pra esse luto
espécie de medo que um julgamento
estamos sempre prontos a jogar o próximo
nós não fazemos é minimizar o que aquela
pessoa passou nós fazemos é mineiro foi
o dia deu a mágoa que teve o que ouviu e
que eu não vi o que eu vi que eu não viu
para viver um tempo passou por meio do
corredor e não falou que é da festa
este julgamento que nós fazemos a outro
calo um dos pais da psicologia dizia nós
só vemos nos outros aquilo que já temos
cá dentro é difícil porque eu tenho
visto outro som brasil aqui foi bem nem
o que minha neta juízo de valor que eu
faça aquela pessoa pois nós não jogamos
só é preciso agarrar um carimbo taxa e
por um casal
este ele está hoje em dia mas é um
objetivo que este revela quanto nós
catalogamos as pessoas e para uma das
coisas que eu falo muito inclusive com
minha filha é uma inspiração e uma ajuda
pra mim sempre neste crescimento
nós não podemos dizer quando a estúpida
estúpida ileso
fazemos todos estão pedindo um capital
muito fora e ter visto outra coisa
qualquer para dizer sobre os outros e
principalmente sobre as provas
isso é o casal nós temos que ter cuidado
e evitarem um ok nós estamos procurando
tantas vezes pois temos outra coisa de
confiar em outros disse franco
eu não provar já não da minha família
comigo nunca não tinha nada para um
homem e até um tempo atrás motorola
screen da criança saudável falava pra
começar a produzir no fundo eu falei
assim nós fazemos nós próprios temos que
ter inimigos e não tem
irmã nós vamos lidar com enormes
intrusiva consegue passar essa mensagem
às pessoas explica 23 ela disse eu não
tenho eles e quando para a china para
falar besteiras loucas voltar com ela
verificou a ouvia sua fama em ensinar
desta desta partilha pura quando elas
mas como não tem inimigos jovens
chamaram todos e que os sacanas
elas talvez sinta diz nada porque estava
em gaza e nós mudamos isso conosco e
hoje há pessoas que antes em casa já tão
tarde com um clarão já consagrados já
estão prontos e é causada pela bomba
igual já começa a nota assim existe um
estado não dá hipótese de um dos
projetos preventivos pois ele estava
aqui com tantos empreendedores do g1
usar um pico de 15 para 20 dias por isso
que vence nesta tarde se preocupe com
esse que eu começava a aumentar a
procura é patriota em condições vai
tomar um banho de água fria já vai sair
na estréia hoje no terminal é melhor do
que ser implantada uma falha no primeiro
porque nós andamos sul sonha em casa com
esta ai valor dentro pronto para lembrar
o filme norte-americano que eu acho que
era em 2009 foi de r 916 creche eu acho
que atração própria da colisão não foi
muito forte e intenso vocês viram mas é
um filme forte logo no princípio um dos
atores principais e assim o emissão
batida tati e beto creche enteada já só
lá vai assim que não tocamos nos braços
não temos um gesto parece só vai mesmo
atuar em um ovo seguinte e quando um
mosquito usando os tipos de um homem que
observam tudo só vai atuar
bill cash uma coisa cada vez com essa
história de amor o filme spring e vai
entrar na sala pelo menos os homens
disseram que todos eles é que a gente
imaginava ter uns que há de facto o
nosso caminho não é esse
e toda essa raiva todo o julgamento
desta culpa todas estas espécies membros
nós estamos a viver estão se tornar um
ciclo de vida porque ele porque nós
queremos 15 entre os pensamentos e
emoções
este registo não estamos a fazer para o
instinto uma reação instintiva uma
resposta do corpo a uma situação
exterior
a solução que estamos a falar é uma
resposta do corpo um pensamento por
vezes não é a finalidade maior parte das
vezes não é resposta ao pensamento e não
sugeria a partir de certa altura já
vamos no quilômetro 21 do niterói falou
há 30 anos naquela fase já que o bc tem
as pernas a correr ou não e nós estamos
nesta fase com este pensamento que esta
forma de luta ao comboio gigantesca está
a condicionar essas nossas emoções
ganhar a vida e com sorriso dessas
emissões dão energia para outros
pensamentos semelhantes e portanto temos
de criar um ciclo vicioso que têm um
cérebro
o lucro do medo que o daniel sá nogueira
um livro muito dinheiro muito
interessante se houvesse em primeiro
mandamento fechamento mesmo nuclear há
como aqui é o medo que no fundo não é
que nós achamos que eles mesmo jogador
medo nuclear cruz para a equipe nós
achamos e não tenho medo de perder o
emprego e não têm medo primeiro namorado
ou namorada que hoje o brasil
eu não tenho medo eu não tenho medo de
perder a confiança de um filho é tudo
quando chove temos medo não
o que explica o facto assim que eu
acredito também e que nós temos mesmo de
não saber lidar com essa situação
essa questão é que na verdade não é um
acontecimento em acharam que nós somos
capazes de levar esse hoje e que
interessava
tivemos exemplos que isso acontece não
temos dúvidas neste projecto fatais
entre clientes e fui e marca e como ela
então investigador nós vimos aqui neste
projeto todos falaram da terra de fora
da água e falar nato tudo que o cliente
trouxer com projetos operadores de
pessoas operadoras iguais a nós e isso
vê outro facto que nós
dá pra ver porque achamos que não
conseguimos lidar irá lá conseguimos
puxar freitas autor português
eu sou que tinha pouco tempo de treinos
livres neste momento mas num livro que
prendeu mais antigos chama eu sou deus
eu tenho um trabalho que dirige uma
mensagem sobre o caça que é o tempo eo
planeta e eu sou muito grata à hora
portugal são apaixonados por futebol que
não cansa de dizer isto que estou há
algum tempo que era chato o amor ea
citação carinho mas a idéia não é só
sobre o cangaço funk é que o que
acontece conosco porque não acho temos
uma barreira do medo que já tem possível
fazer isto não avançamos naquela paixão
que temos como rita geralmente falou
hoje aqui não andamos aqui o pastor não
queria mais a preparação é uma hipótese
então nós estamos convictos fechando que
seguimos condicionar os brasileiros
notíca mente o crise pedro chagas
freitas entre as pessoas diz jacinto não
se isto fosse livro não avançasse força
avançado
por isso mesmo quando alguns tarde para
um vibrador hora e pensadora indiano
ficou mais tarde quando se com o coxa
o fim do medo como ferrugem fico lá e
destrói a inteligência em um livro com o
mesmo tempo precisamente por agências de
inteligência da intelectualidade dizendo
que a tranqüilidade é uma cédula falsa
porque gostava que eu aprendi que eu fui
ver os livros que eu fui buscar a meta
não é minha entre os dias 05 o
crescimento da confiança interior com o
meu caminho da minha ligação ao mundo
que é única e que buscava todos nós
fazer e isso é que nós estamos a fazer
essa ligação chinalco nós precisamos ter
ao mundo e que nos deixamos de carlos
cruz pra ele não merece ter essa ligação
que é estrutural porque o que essa
chance é como nós com um tem uma palavra
e essa palavra e amor
quando alguém fala da moura fica tudo
bem entre as quedas nos honra josé
pedroso o inter e votar na maionese o
ataque era uma voz rouca e amore itália
le brésil a mesma coisa dizia mais amor
determinantes
é da natureza humana do que se possa
pensar a fase é tão bonita é a essência
da natureza humana talvez aquela que os
potentes que não chega a dizer que eu
vou dizer não liberou os times co
não não sai não sai não é ser um pai o
irmão eo el mar com não sai não vale a
pena então entrou mas aqui não há
hipótese nenhuma
seu pai yohane esse é meu pai de cor até
isso me lembra né
não é isso gente tem essa mulher que
está a fazer falta é isso mesmo que nós
precisamos gerir da forma como de
treinos neste neste caminho para
chegarmos a esse amor que é tão
estruturante que nos faz tanta falta
nós precisamos claramente viver estas
opções
nós temos uma tendência para fugir do
mesmo que ele não é em geral do ons que
o autor norte americano tem um livro
crime estava em chamas a marca é
levantar se do mesmo e eu estou aqui
exatamente essa pec não dá pra não ter
medo eu acredito piamente como tudo na
vida não é punitiva avaianos não é assim
não é não qualquer coisa e assim a favor
de qualquer coisa eu não sou contra o
autocontrole incluir eu sou a favor de
qualquer coisa
e é exatamente a mesma coisa o final
amorim ou mesmo se você sai de água nós
temos um contra o outro e neste lugar da
maneira como eu gostei de ter amor eu
queria falar comigo eu estou estou com
medo de baixar a nota da s energia está
apurada e não têm as mesmas baixar a
nota e amor possuir produzir nem sei
qual é o que me interessa fazer é o
hamburgo nos liberta do b não há como
não é que eu vou aceitar ficar pra não
acontecer qualquer coisa sobre o que
isso vai acontecer
e este truque precisamente nós vamos
fazer que é viver essas emoções
experiência mas podemos transferir a
tendência de fugir do medo não dá não
chega e é preciso encontrar essa dor dói
aqui
o escritor russo dizia único medo que eu
tenho para não ser digno do meu
sofrimento e para denominar traz um
sentindo isto é sempre incrementador
convencer cecília fonseca hoje no
princípio é isso o trajeto é sempre
incrementador exatamente isso é para nos
superarmos o nosso próximo todos nós
próprios nestes desafios
nós encontramos aqui é exatamente isso
que estamos a falar para conseguirmos ir
ainda mais além
nesta superação pois é preciso viver
essas emissões mas conseguimos
transcender a palavra propositadamente
esta não esquecer não é deixar pra trás
e essas demissões surgem são humanas são
normais mas vivem nelas não vamos culpar
pelo inter por cima
vamos aprender através delas podemos ir
mais além
isso é claramente o nosso desafio e uma
estrutura pequena chamada helena pimenta
tem um livro que se chama precisamente
viver as emoções
outro livro pequeno ingerir cinco como é
que nós tendo para viver uma emoção
posso usar outra para superar uma vez um
lado o amor como é que nós conseguimos
dar essa volta por este lado viver essas
ilusões e ela escreve que a verdadeira
liberdade de escolher o que quer ver os
chamaram o alecrim no dia 3 novembro de
sobre f1 num atentado no ataque à
imprensa
era um jovem e 28 anos e ficou eu e uma
criança de 7 meses
o caminho que eu fiz foi começar a
escrever para mim essa dor
essa mágoa essa raiva aproveitar essa
culpa que eu expressei o trans endereça
as emissões à altura nos crítico foi
fazendo no bloco que hoje se tornou um
livro que está também publicado em
português que escreveu esta frase que dá
título ao livro não terão o meu blog
isto é uma opção
ela tinha assim somos 21 e nós somos
mais fortes do que quaisquer 17 do mundo
estava em bruxelas neste dia eu falar à
comunidade portuguesa com uma grande
amiga na fria e passou como você estava
em bruxelas pois assim ver estes
exemplos atentados no próximo vamos
fazer esse caminho
ela tem os seus três filhos os três
marias como ela chega à praia para todos
os portugueses e todos nós que vivemos
este mesmo que a justiça mas de moura
o que é isso que nos faz dar a volta não
nos podemos deixar levar por esse mesmo
endereço
o comboio ainda melhor porque nós já
temos que resolver e para ultrapassar
esta opção
pelo padrão gravar outro toque só para
falar sobre o programa mas o problema é
um gesto que não é que suprimirá não é
eu estou certo eo que está errado
o programa é um enorme ato de humildade
não é uma fraqueza você fizer isso podem
fazer tudo é um ato de nossa coragem
para superar essas outras emoções
isso é que é o verdadeiro pra nós
podemos dizer efetivamente amor
outro advogado chamado antónio pinto vai
ter um livro que se chama o lucro como
critério de gestão e este é também um
ato de coragem publicar um livro assim
ir para com critérios estão a dizer sim
o primeiro a sentir bonita de sempre
pois então voltei a morar para o karim
não e viver sem amor eu critérios da
própria gestão ser o amor e aprendi
nessa altura que o amor ao próximo
estamos também dando fantástica que o
ambiente não explicável é que o próximo
não é convocar os agentes sequer país
vai cair no chão ele é palco assim o
próximo é no próximo disco que eu vou
jogar porque eu chefiava a lei contou
cada caixa tem um familiar completou eu
tocava sentir um chefe alguém eu vou sim
o que você o que é isso nós temos que
pensar o aborto nas pessoas o amor ao
próximo que tenho agora terceiros em
qualquer lado assim que eu faço um
projeto fantástico é muita coisa
este amor ao próximo que desaparece que
nos falta é este nosso caminho e que os
papéis da nossa vida sobre amor ao
próximo
estou entrando na reta final trazendo
assim uma história que contei no
hospital santa maria inspirada primeiro
na minha filha é sempre uma inspiração
pra isso que eu estava no hospital
shamarita bonita eu sou uma menina fazia
uma sopa aspecto eu ea praça comprava
jogamos todos manhã
depois quando estava em troca irá gravar
tentar uma cravada zé das couves e 11
anos que ficarão superiores como é que
alguém as pessoas não só pra mim o
caminho é possível termos convênios
chega a cnet tuba o que eu faço e namur
só isso pois eu aplicava não vamos agora
que com isso uma série de gestos
femininos como as cenouras criam seus
senhores deputados e penteados os blocos
com cinco motos fizeram para poucos
segundos todos estão sempre a chorar
porque estavam céticos canta bom quando
é só agora é pensar no exemplo que os
gestores podem ser crimes o humor pode
ser um gesto
esse sim um abraço nós possamos fazer eu
vou distribuir o jogo dos miúdos todos e
quando temos a sala cheia uma única não
tem o seu contadas as histórias que
agora só ficar aqui um carinho e por um
minuto
vamos dar a moura no roubo nunca nunca o
nilton teve perguntava o que isso é
nunca tantos minutos antes outro mais à
frente mas também um minuto eu faço o
papel também em quatro anos que eu peço
para estarem à porta da sala e não
estamos todos mais próxima de hoje o
seguro da estação e os links e nos olhos
que os miúdos é o mesmo com a gente mas
nós mostramos hoje que o rio é o amor
projetado da vida convite de um projeto
realizado dirige imaginem nós
conseguimos fazer isso com uma sopa que
nós não conseguimos fazer com as pessoas
esse é o nosso desafio hoje é eu voltar
aqui uma outra história que eu queria
conhecer o ovo e vou terminar com
galinha
essa foi minha companheira não aceitava
durante os anos nas histórias para
crianças em idéias projetos e até 2002
ela estava entre fazer figura do próprio
pautem que o chrome de areia
esta é uma história uma galinha que
representa o amor e que é traçado com
boy fica com uma pata presa na linha
louco lo e quando fiquei com o pé preso
quando começa a chover o comboio longe
com um ataque pirata e um baita vez mais
perto de mim não conjuga vez que ele se
mantenha como está no projeto da justiça
tem dois anos três andares é maior do
que eu amava como o iptu
o é é é que como já mesmo com um técnico
ele vai
foi isso que ela disse que ganhou
sempre no meio como a origem do que
estamos a viver pelo povo como disso
também pela galinha pelo valor a eles
que eu acredito
hoje no intervalo e não é todos esses
vinhos portugueses eu fui falar com
jorge gonçalves o nosso cliente é
fantástica que esteve hoje convivemos
com intervenção já a lista eu por
exemplo estou dizendo agora todo o
trabalho e eu ainda estou porque eu
tenho imenso medo de tocar em público
hoje eu sou hoje eu fui linha
hoje eu fui amor
achamos nós inspirar por eu e por todos
aqui os portugueses que falaram os
obrigado pela vossa apertar
agora podiam
ian